part c
find all values of x on the interval
negative 4 is less than x is less than 3
for which the graph of g has a point of
inflection give a reason for your answer
so an inflection point an inflection
point is a point where the sign of the
second derivative sine of
second derivative
changes
changes so if you take the second
derivative at that point or as we go
close to that point or as we cross that
point it goes from positive to negative
or negative to positive and to think
about that visually you can think of
some examples so if you have a curve
that looks something like this
if you have a curve that looks something
like this you'll notice that over here
the slope is negative but it's
increasing it's getting less negative
less negative then it goes to zero then
it keeps increasing slope is increasing
increasing all the way in there and then
it starts getting less positive so it
starts decreasing so it's increasing the
slope is increasing over this point
right over here so even though the slope
is negative it's getting less negative
over here so it's increasing and then
the slope keeps increasing gets getting
more and more positive up to about this
point and then the slope is positive but
then it becomes less positive so the
slope begins decreasing after that so
then the slope begins decreasing after
that so this right over here is a point
of inflection the the the slope has gone
from increasing to decreasing and the
other thing happened if slope went from
decreasing to increasing that would also
be a point of inflection so if this was
maybe some type of a trigonometric curve
then you might see something like this
and so this also this also would be a
point of inflection but for this you
know our g of x is kind of hard to
visualize the way they've defined it
right over here so the best way to think
about it is just figure out where its
second derivative has a sign change and
to think about that we have to find its
second derivative so let's write g of x
over here we know g of x is equal to 2x
plus the definite integral from 0 to x
of f of t
dt
we've already taken this derivative but
we'll do it again g prime of x is equal
to 2
plus fundamental theorem of calculus the
derivative of this right over here is
just f of x
and if we have the second derivative of
g g prime prime of x this is equal to
derivative of 2 is just a 0 and the
derivative of f of x is f prime of x
so asking where this has a sign change
asking where our second derivative has a
sign change is equivalent to asking
where does the first derivative of f
have a sign change
sign change and asking where the first
derivative of f has a sign change is
equivalent to saying where does the
slope of f have a sign change you could
view this as a the slope the slope or
the instantaneous slope of f so we want
to know where that when the slope of f
has a sign change so let's think about
it over here the slope is positive it's
going up it's up it's getting it's
increasing but it's positive and that's
what we care about so let's write it
i'll do it in green so the slope is
positive
this entire time it's increasing it's
increasing it's positive it's getting
less positive now it's starting to
decrease but the slope is still positive
the slope is still positive all the way
until we get right over there it seems
like it gets pretty close to zero and
then the slope gets a negative and then
right over here the slope is negative
the slope is negative the slope is
negative right over here so this is
interesting because because even though
f is actually not differentiable right
here so f is not differentiable at that
point right over there and you can see
because the slope goes pretty close to
zero then it just jumps to negative
three so you have a discontinuity you
have a discontinuity of the derivative
right over there but we do have a sign
change we go from having a positive a
positive slope on this part of the curve
to having a negative slope over this
part of the curve so we experience a
sign change right over here at x is
equal to zero a sign change in the first
derivative of f
which which is the same thing as saying
a sign change in the second derivative
of g and a sine change in the second
derivative of g tells us that when x is
equal to zero that when x is equal to
zero we have a point the graph of g has
a point of inflection